good morning Hank so here's how the
Paper Towns tour went I said goodbye to
my beloved vacation hammock and also my
beloved family and then drove across
Michigan to Lansing blasting the
mountain goats the whole way stopped
only once on the drive emergency then I
was in the airport and then on a plane
and then I was driving through New York
City watching the sunset behind the
skyline my hotel room was fancy but I
couldn't sleep so I woke up groggy
ironed clothes brush teeth got dressed
and met up with my friend publicist at
least Marshall and then headed over to
the YouTube space to meet next week left
with the Gregory Brothers and then did
an interview with The Young Turks where
one of the interviewers was wearing a
pink shirt with a green dragon breathing
orange fire like young Margo does in
Paper Towns and my life felt weird Paper
Towns is about the challenge of
understanding that other people are as
complex as you are which is very hard
for anyone but especially for anyone
living inside this weird publicity
machine because it does ultimately sort
of commodify everyone it touches and I
was thinking about that as I saw
two-dimensional images of my friends or
possibly like characters plastered all
over New York City anyway got some lunch
from my publisher Julie Strauss Gable
who has on her wall D first map ever
made containing aglow in New York and we
talked about how much she liked the
movie and then I had to go to Burberry
to get the suit for next week's premiere
and on the way I confessed to at least
that I was a little bit tired and she
pointed out that technically the tour
had not yet begun hood Indianapolis and
broke through my hometown before
experiencing the unspeakable luxury of
sleeping in my own bed the next morning
I discovered a trove of clean pants
which never happens even at the fanciest
hotels said I met up with Halston sage
and NAT and we did interviews and
interviews and interviews before heading
over to the Marathi ever I signed books
for a while in a suit that I only now
realized was quite wrinkly and then
there were more interviews and more
interviews and then once I was good and
sweaty I got my picture taken with Navin
Halston then the show started not his
brother Alex played some songs together
and I loved both those guys so much and
I loved watching them play music
together because it reminds me of my own
relationship with my brother except for
the part about how Hank refuses to let
me into his band simply because I cannot
sing or play any instruments then I went
out on stage with our great host Akilah
Hughes and I felt this immense wave of
energy and then the mayor of
Indianapolis came out and declared July
14th 2015 to be John Green Day which you
know very weird and afterwards I got to
meet Anthony and Jack from the
Indianapolis Colts and then everyone was
feeling pretty good and we flew to
Columbus I got to have a drink with
Aquila and then I
went to bed I'm not sure why videotaped
every bed on tour I think I was just
excited about the prospect of sleeping
woke up a couple hours later just a
smidge tired but the car taking me to
interviews had ice-cold Coke Zero in it
so that was nice met up with Cara and
Cara tried to adopt this Mongoose like
thing named Sherman and then we did a TV
interview where Carl reluctantly beatbox
that I was told that the anchors really
liked my book no fault in these stars
then we did some more interviews and
then back at the hotel I signed some
looks and then went to the theater where
we got to sign for fans for a while and
then there were interviews and
interviews and interviews until I was
good and sweaty which meant it was time
to be photographed the Groton Columbus
was amazing and asked great questions
and I kept thinking about how long ago
my college days in Ohio felt but before
I could get properly nostalgic we were
yanked away to the airport and a flight
to Dallas the next morning I got dressed
brush my teeth and found NAT and Halston
atop a balcony god I love those guys
then I got my makeup done and then
interviews and interviews and interviews
went to my room to sign some more books
and then headed over to the theater
where Dallas was hot now I didn't have a
thermometer with me but I think it was
in the neighborhood of 15 point 7
million degrees Kelvin fortunately
because she's a good friend Elise was
kind enough not to videotape me getting
photographed while my face melted from
the heat but then after just two changes
of shirts I was able to meet our host
Gabby and Alison from just between us
and then listen to st. Motel and finally
meet the amazing crowd in Dallas who
were just awesome and then suddenly it
was over and we were on a plane to LA
thank the Paper Towns movie is out in
most of the world now and I'm so
grateful to everyone who's watched it
and shared their responses via nerd
fight areas wall of Cal hashtag it's
been a long and difficult two months for
me I've missed my family a lot and I'm
so glad to be home with them now but
what an adventure that week was and like
the best adventures it brought me closer
to people I loved so thanks to all of
them and to everyone who made the movie
Hank thank you for a great VidCon I am
now going to sleep until Friday I will
see you then